This chart summarizes some of the discussion so far. Content deals with
the content of knowledge. Encoding deals with the representation of knowledge.
Content and form. The content of knowledge can be visuospatial,
that deals with what and where. Where is spatial, what is visual, and
the encoding of the visuospatial knowledge could be either analogical or
propositional. An analogical inquiry of visuospatial knowledge is a structural
correspondence between the encoding and the external world that is being
represented. In the propository presentation of visuospatial knowledge, there is
no such correspondence. Examples of this verbal knowledge include things like
scripts or going to a restaurant. The script for going to a restaurant again can
represented either propositionally or potentially analogically. And
a propository presentation of the kind we say we may have tracks and
props and actors. In an analogical representation of the script for
going to a restaurant, we may have a short movie. In much of the codes,
we have dealt with the right hand side of this chart with verbal knowledge and
prepositional presentations. Part of the point of this lesson on visuospatial
knowledge and reasoning is that reasoning and knowledge can be visuospatial, and
representations can be analogical. But we have yet
to fully understand the role of human cognition and you [UNKNOWN] agents that
can deal with visuospatial knowledge and analogical representation.